americans receive nearly 130 million  robo calls a day but today is the last  chance for phone companies to adopt a  new technology that  could stop many of those annoying calls  the calls are of course often scams con  artists can spoof numbers to make it  look like they're coming from our area  with our area code or even a government  agency  well now the fcc deadline is here for  major u.s phone providers to adopt a new  technology that is called  stir shaken now this validates a call  and means the number you see  is legit so in theory  a fake phone call or a spoofed phone  call will not be able to get through  shaken and stir is supposed to be built  into the networks  so you won't have to do anything for it  to work  many companies do offer apps with extra  protection that can help make sure the  calls you receive  are real